so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect
[Music]
hello what's up guys I'm Thomas
dobiziola whatever you want to call me
I'm here with my co-host Marty O'Neal
what's up guys we're back season two
wrapped in the [__] grab strong
yo I'm sorry I mean to YouTube not to
everybody else this is how we want to
talk
um
all right I didn't expect that what's up
guys how you doing that's fine he's got
a five hour drive from across town
basically
um guys this is season two finale all
right this is it I know last week we're
like this is it it's not okay
real quick update
as you can see if you're not watching
from if you're if you're on the road
season one table is in front oh geez no
this is a season one table guys it's how
we start is how everything started right
here Marty and I went to our new studio
today Malcolm media we went to our new
studio
looks good
doesn't seem real it looks awesome but
our table that we use every week
we took it apart took it over there it
doesn't fit it's too wide so uh yeah we
couldn't bring it back because me and
Marty are not Bob the Builder we don't
know how to take things apart and
Trent's not here so last episode ever
alright guys this is it last episode in
this Warehouse that we are filming this
not gonna happen again this is it thank
you for everyone that's been here for a
hundred and what like 100 couple
episodes I think yeah oh yeah thank you
is it 112 somewhere red one there
whatever 36 plus 66 is definitely not
112 sir okay 102. all right is it no we
just had episode 100 like a week ago
we're like [__] a couple weeks ago
yeah 102. this would be 103. all right
you got it
96 was 36 is
yeah okay yeah okay I thought I was
tripping but we're gonna see we might
trim up that table to make it fit we got
another good option so we got two good
options for the table on the new set
that sure looks sexy it looks really
really cool but with that being said
guys it's the last episode season three
starts next week
weird
we said season two by the end of that
year two we'll probably be like trying
to sign a deal with somebody doing
something we called it directly find it
whoever can find it in the first season
we said that like around you know year
two start of year three big build up I
remember last year when I was on Set uh
for these commercials I had the call
with Lewis and he really liked it out
with the vision and what what do you
think like it could be like this what if
we power all this on like yeah bro
that's exactly what we should be doing
it's crazy crazy to think about it now
but we've got a strong Team Soft
proclaimed Black Ops of the [__]
podcasts I'm excited this is gonna be
really cool before we continue Marty
what did you do this week
it's been an eventful week guys it's
been a very eventful week we all know
this time of year Super Bowl season
which means I snap into [__]
action for about a week or two yeah and
go on a psychotic spree of commercial
filming behind the scenes so that's
where I've been all week where did you
who did you happen to film with this
week Martin so uh I was back on set for
the first two days with T-Mobile uh in
our string of Zach Braff and Donald uh
Faison from Scrubs they have the longest
I don't these Four's got like six seven
eight commercials that they've done it's
like a whole string of like musical
commercials that's cool but uh
I'm not gonna really ruin this total
surprise here on the podcast I don't
think you did on Instagram okay all
right well we'll go for this one all
right
just let them know just let him know a
little bit Royale with cheese bro it's a
good [__] milkshake
that's crazy guys we I guess man
my I like to think my thing is I'm the
Pulp Fiction guy everybody knows I love
Pulp Fiction okay it's the only movie I
ever reference it comes up about five
times the episode
all right
two days in a row onset BTS
[__] John Travolta
awesome I probably demonetized but who
cares yeah that's not the problem it's
about bro guys so
coolest guy ever you know we uh and it's
a really bad it's a it's a it's a I've
realized that like no I haven't really
been I wasn't Starstruck but it was just
one of those moments when you're filming
such a legend through your own lens and
you see them in your camera's viewfinder
this lens right here it's different like
when you see it in his eyes all that
Legend in his eyes went through the lens
like it's just different I just see him
dancing on bleachers he did the [__]
dance man isn't that awesome you did the
little when he did it I was talking
about Danny Zuko Greece but yes yes see
the pulpation dance yeah I don't know
you know what I couldn't why you told me
he did the Pulp Fiction yes I just kind
of try to look away and not entertain
myself
bro I would have lost my [__] I'm not
gonna sugarcoat it like aren't you the
angel for Michael
[Laughter]
just obscure movies like he's like yes
yeah I did do that movie that would have
been cool and I felt I realized in that
moment like I'm an interviewer now all I
want to do is interview this man
differently than he's ever been
interviewed you know and you're just
you're looking at somebody who's been a
legend for so long since the 60s is full
invented disco put disco on and then did
Grease and then like by the time you
circled around a Pulp Fiction he had
already had a whole career he was in his
late 30s 40s when that [__] came about
late 40s probably for purple fiction
he's almost 70 now maybe maybe in the
70s yeah yeah but 26. the one little
moment that really stood out and you got
to keep in mind like
with the BTS it's very tricky because
compared to the rest of the set I look
like Paparazzi I'm floating around and
I'm kind of trying to stay out of the
way not be distracting at all but
there's high potential for me to be
distracting yeah during the shoot in
between takes last thing you want to do
is annoy the talent so I'm very behind
the scenes I have no like I'm not trying
to be up in the mix when I'm filming
behind the scenes but when they
introduce me to them uh I always
introduce myself you know they introduce
me like this is behind the scenes Marty
whatever and he was like shaking a bunch
of people's hands and uh like I stuck
out my hand and you didn't see it right
away and I just pulled it back like no
big deal if we don't you know what I
mean but then he was like oh no he
stopped and just the the tiniest little
gesture of like oh no
nice to meet you just that little eye
contact oh bro let me make sure I snap
you up that was like everything and it
makes me think about the meet and greets
and [__] like those conversations that
you have over and over like I don't know
I haven't felt like that connection with
somebody I looked up to but yeah in a
long time when that little handshake and
that eye contact of what's up bro good
to meet you you know so sick yeah yeah
that [__] felt great so we did I did two
full days way out far in the middle of
uh nowhere basically early call times
and then uh that went great and then I
had a day off and then I came back and I
do have to be very discreet about this
one uh for a 5 a.m call time
with a very very very big movie star
inside a real if we can't say don't even
say it yeah huge yeah
and then Partners in some of my favorite
movies yeah and we'll find out you guys
will know in the uh once the Super Bowl
airs but I always recorded by Marty
filmed that one or last year I'm like yo
that Marty filmed that one yeah yeah
yeah we're gonna we'll we'll fill it in
after the Super Bowl airs but that was
great man I've been out here grinding so
that means [__] we're up at three we're
out there five we're getting it in like
I love it it was just a real big team
effort everybody got it done came out
real great feeling like a pro nothing
went wrong no camera stolen no camera
stolen everything intact came back and I
was able to book two of my boys on
really big shoots too
so I booked my boy Hawk Down in Texas to
film the meet and greets he crushed it
we still booked track to go film
I think he can't even say I don't even
know if he's I don't even Trent got the
gold film Super Bowl commercial too
another yeah for the first time out in
the desert and [__] so huge talent and
crushed it can't even say that yeah so
worldwide global
that's crazy bro yeah so it's been a big
week here on the videography side we're
out here hustling real hard we had the
sets being moved here for the podcast
and [__] we're orchestrating that we
just got past the Ted Talk and Houston
Texas Dallas yeah that's [__] meet
and greets damn that was a lot yeah you
ready smoke Joy
I'm ready too the last time I bring that
thing out in this where this is weird
man this is very very weird this is a
big win for the community we've been
talking about this for so long and it's
one of those things that's like people
have seen now like when big moves happen
and stuff like this like we're so
just like uh treat the podcast which was
such respect like this deal took a year
to happen yeah we were in no rush to
make this [__] happen let it happen in
its own time we got to kind of zip her
in and get to know the team before we
really moved in which was amazing I hope
they don't watch it on page but I'm
about to bring some Zips ounces to
everybody that'd be the Epic most epic
thing ever like can we start a new show
today the guy brought me two zips
you know not every day not every time
but I'm just saying just the intro yeah
yeah that's how you do it that's filming
for us thanks for doing our audio thanks
for writing the notes down like that's
sick and everybody smokes
you want to win somebody over give them
some free weed and everybody seemed cool
everybody all the new team seems epic we
have a team
which is weird and smart and invested
and they care and they get it they yeah
they get it they understand
so it's gonna be super sick so Marty got
to film with John Travolta which is
insane
so weird guys
like we said in the Ted Talk man I never
even if I wouldn't uh if I would not
took all that time to learn the camera
spend all that money to invest in all my
[__] it would have been very easy not to
I could have been the graphic designer I
would have never been able to do all
this cool [__] yep but level up all
right so with that being said the first
thing I'm gonna talk about
this right here on my shirt we just
dropped the video
yeah
the reupstore.com that's our new
business all right guys you guys know
that with my homies Tony and Jay we
dropped a video last week we we opened
up a month ago right
we're doing cool we're doing I can't
really post on Instagram about smoke
shop stuff and tag because I get deleted
sales are doing cool not like I expect
like are pushed because we show it show
shirt show you know hoodies and all that
that it's easy to sell that stuff it's
because it's you can Market you have to
be so discreet with a legal bong like
it's so dumb anyway we did a video like
going over that we started a new company
thank you guys if you ordered or even
went on there and dropped a like thank
you the drop went
now to drop the video
skyrocketed our [__] so hard
it did I had to ask like how much what
how many orders do we have
like I had to make sure that I was
hearing it right
we had to go re-get a whole new
truckload of boxes and stuff well it's
not really put out until you make a
video about it exactly but you know what
I'm saying like people you guys thank
you thank you for responding and like
really giving a [__] it was
awesome so what are the price ranges
that people are like I mean we have
stuff for five bucks we have stuff for
150 we have stuff for trades or five
dollars a dab nail is 15 20 Terps per
sets thirty dollars
like that's unreal dude that's the
prices you should be getting in the
wholesale downtown yeah
we're really like people are happy man
we have torches emails rigs everything
you can think of our own butane I mean
our own alcohol ISO it's it's going guys
want to say thank you guys so much for
that I'm gonna start off with that
season finale we just got the shirts our
first shirt I ever got so I'm like you
know what I'm wearing it today
um thank you guys it really
lit a fire under us to like all right
this is gonna this is gonna work if
that's what we can do with just one
video in a month wait till we're really
doing videos and marketing and doing
it's going to be fun
it's just another Lane it's another Lane
that I think we could do really well in
to offer higher quality affordable for
[__] to the fans yeah oh we got like a
12 000 rig on there now too oh damn the
Darby the Darby Holmes piece and
Mothership we're about to fly to Seattle
and go visit Mothership and buy a bunch
of them for the store make a whole Vlog
out of it wow that's awesome yeah we're
gonna go over there like um I want that
one I want that one uh that one oh let's
go home but at Mothership I got their
head is that going to Beaverton and
going to cheat Nike like oh [__] we're
here I'm excited
um they're kind of uh
should tease this video we're about to
drop tomorrow too
oh well it's out my mom took it I
finally put it off well this video oh
yeah yeah that's right whoa usually
that's it yeah okay
um yeah I finally convinced my mom to
take a dab I recorded all of it
[Music]
is [__] she was pissed she was [__]
high dude so I think I'm gonna get my
mom to do it man yo my mom's I told you
my mom's like working out and [__] again
when I was young my mom was a taebo
[__] used to be all over that [__] oh
no [__] yeah she my mommy should be like
rocked out and like in shape then she
stopped giving a [__] and she got all
butt hurt about it it's like I don't
care but now she cares again so it's
pretty awesome she's an addict she's
going at it it's pretty sick yo right
now you're in the chat Rocco is the most
peer pressure [__] of all time
in that video that [__] is hilarious
he's like we'll like you more we'll
respect you more if you take a dab Oh I
thought you meant at the gym he's been
forcing her to go to the gym he's her
trainer oh no [__] he's using that
energy yeah no yeah he's [__] with
her like positively nice yeah he's a
fool dude
um but yeah
oh he does oh cool every day oh [__]
yeah
yeah let's go Rocco yeah he's super in
shape you don't think because he wears
big clothes I thought he's just skinny
as [__] no Rocco's pretty [__] rocked
out it's pretty nice it's awesome
he's like the ax body commercial
part two kids uh-huh the tall cut up
Skitty guys yeah what do we got here
that is pineapple Sunrise mixed with
lemon
poppers the homies that [__] sounds
healthy yeah it does here we go yeah
that's my homies that kush clinic and
[__] then where I've been getting on my
weed shout out um yeah they're [__]
they're awesome
um so here we go
on to the next piece of information I'm
going to break it down for you guys it
might get real upsetting it might get
fun it might start screaming I don't
know what's going on yet
but here we go I don't know what's
coming here oh the meet and greets oh
okay yeah here we go oh yeah oh [__]
okay [__]
what's up guys taking a moment to talk
about one of our long time sponsors and
this is manscaped right now did you know
manscape just dropped some products for
your beards yes manscape is taking it
above and beyond and above the waistline
guys this is not for your dick introduce
you for manscape beer hedger Pro kit for
all the people out there that shape
their beard try to get that look now you
can do it with manscape five o'clock
Shadows gigantic beards whatever you got
manscape can control it first this is a
cordless trimmer second with the rotary
wheel there are 20 different beard Lake
settings 20 different settings so you
don't have to have a drawer full of 16
attachments it's one attacher that does
20 different settings guys right now go
to manscape.com forward slash Yola
that's 20 off of everything and anything
you can possibly buy and free shipping
all you got to do is use code Yola
manscape does not stop at just the trim
they just introduced beard shampoo and
conditioner so right now you can get the
beard kit it has three free gifts a
beard comb brush and scissors a whole
kit to make sure your beard doesn't look
like [__] so right now get 20 off of
every everything and free shipping by go
to manscape.com forward slash YOLO
that's our code and that's it remember
the new beard hedger one stroke one
guard 20 different lengths and always
thank you so much for supporting the
sponsors that support us back to the
episode
so as you know
um we've been doing the dopest meet and
greets we did LA New York Chicago
Indiana
Miami and then this past weekend was
Dallas Texas and Houston we did two
cities in Texas because Texas is massive
so let me break it down to what happened
guys all right I already know text I
don't travel to Texas because it's a
legal State I don't want to get arrested
and go to jail in Texas for
Gilead what a it's Gilead what a good
way to put it it's Gilead for potheads
yeah it's Gilead thank you
yeah
and the the outfit is a cowboy hat
are you ready let's kill yet I hate you
so much that's from uh that means till
just in case you guys didn't know so get
to Tech I love Texas all right but every
time I say the word Texas I have to dumb
old Texas remember in SpongeBob tried to
make Sandy Cheeks not move back to Texas
and he keeps making fun of yo that's how
I feel every time I hear the word Texas
but I don't feel that way about it I
just like SpongeBob okay so if you ever
hear me say Dumbo Texas it's just it's
just SpongeBob guys and Patrick all
right
Texas is dope everybody was so [__]
polite
super polite anyway we get to Dallas uh
it's me John and Rosie only the team
didn't come this time it was like it was
everything just didn't work out to where
we can get more of our homies out there
coming usually we come with like five
homies we make a trip out of the you
know what I mean
support the city but
this one this time I'm like dude it's
illegal State I don't really want to be
out vlogging getting high and [__] we're
the only fools outside people don't
really walk around downtown Dallas it
was nobody outside
I might be wrong but somebody told me
like oh this is cold it was super cold
anyway
go to Dallas
we pull up to the smoke shop the owner
already told us a full slept there and
they were out there like three in the
morning so I'm like okay this is gonna
be a big one
I pull up
and the line is like
it's the shopping mall so the line goes
how can I give him a reference
the line goes like you know the shopping
center outside there's a couple stores a
Sandwich Spot a two tacos place a
football field is a good reference a
football field thank you it's about 150
yeah 100 yards deep a line I'm like oh
all right cool wrap around the building
right when I'm unloading our shirts
you're gonna do three shares free
posters and print out like concert
posters I signed them and [__]
the owners come up like yo cops already
showed up bro and they start breaking it
down because I we brought four we sent
out a shitload of uh dopest dabs so we
could have a dab bar give it away for
[__] free like yo you guys don't like
take it [__] dab you're 21 take a
[__] dab why not like it'd be sick as
hell all right okay they have a dab bar
of rigs lined up like oh you're inside
wow you want to hit this it's legal
the white man I walked up like the cops
are here already they've already been
bugging us and it's in the morning I was
gonna say what time is this I think it
might be like 11 or 12. I can't remember
we started late on that one because it
was a Friday
so we get things that cops are here like
they're bugging they're [__] already
harassing us and [__] like are you
[__] kidding me
skyrise vapor in Dallas is a super nice
looking shop super sick
so I go we're doing the meet and greet I
know none of what happens until I talk
to Rosie at the hotel
I don't move I don't leave my spot I'm
in one spot handing the shirt talking to
each person as they come up we saw about
1400 1200 people that day
and these conversations are hey
thanks for watching they're [__]
whatever until that person is done
talking so times that by 10 minutes of
Peace damn near this one was more like
seven seven minutes on this one Indiana
was like 15. so many people this is like
seven minutes a piece for each person
so the day's going on the day's going on
you know everything's going great
everybody's just so damn happy and like
stoked and to everybody that brought
toys and [__] I'm not saying thank you
for bringing me stuff I'm just saying if
you like the people that did that's
awesome thank you very much I have your
toy toots in the mail
um because I had to mail back people
give me too much [__] I couldn't even
put in my suitcase dude
um
anyway uh shout out to you bro the big
ass street signs the adobe's usual sign
all that [__]
this is what happened going throughout
the day and it's time goes by so fast we
started like 12 40. I like my phone as
five
I've been here for five hours all right
damn still talking still going and I
don't eat I don't go to the bat I'm like
I'm in like adrenaline mode I don't know
what it is I was trying to explain to
the Shoppers like how the [__] did you
not sit down or go or stop
and I'm like dude every time I'm done
with the conversation
the next person's face is so lit up on
my
[__] yeah like I'm ready to like
i p it's not the conversation the same
question like who gives a [__] bro it's
different person every single time it's
a different reaction I read people so
well that I like when I say certain
thing I'm like oh okay I'm gonna keep
talking about okay oh let me ask that
okay you wanna take a quick picture
let's sign this for you I I don't know
how many pairs of [__] shoes I signed
probably [__] 100 pairs of shoes I
cut signed so many skateboards is
another car
sign another car dashboard again this
will look better though
um so everything's going good about
seven o'clock I look to my left like
there's just cops standing right next to
me like what the [__]
I don't look at them and I just keep
shaking the person's hand and keep
talking we're
I don't give a [__] I'm just still
talking and they're talking to the owner
and Rosie I'm like what the [__]
so periodically they're checking in
telling me like hey the cops are
harassing people outside
so the cops in Forney Texas you guys
need to go work out get some Hobbies
because you guys are [__] whack
damn that was good Marty Nelson laughed
oh I didn't expect that at all
um
thank you for being chill but you guys
are [__] whack for wasting your time
the Constable oh guys I guess it's like
a a cop because it wasn't even working
sat in his own truck right outside for
eight hours straight to make sure we
didn't do anything
all these people are just smiling so
stoked talking to each other in a line
the shortest weight was five five and a
half hours
did you have to explain like this [__]
is hhc this is legal here I didn't talk
to the couple but I'm saying like Rosie
had to do all that yeah they knew they
knew and they started going up to be
well let me see your ID you're underage
yeah you're allowed to get an autograph
it's a meet and greet it's a what are
you saying because we gave away like
five we always give away like thousand
dollars worth of [__] we just look at
the shop go hey I want to buy all that
right there and start giving it away
give it away it's raffle tick that's why
we bring raffle tickets in the
microphone yeah so
if I was standing in a line to see
somebody I really like and I got to meet
him I'd be stoked if I was standing in
line I want a [__] 400 bomb like oh
[__] I'm going home with this thing so
that's why we did it and it started
getting cold so we just started raffling
off all the like the jackets they sell
you know what I'm saying and by raffle I
mean free we're not Char you know what
I'm saying yeah
and apparently every time someone won a
ball you have to check their ID you
can't just give somebody a bond because
they won
you know the guy would check their ID
that worked at the shop and then Rosie
told me all this after that the cops
were coming up and like give me your ID
how old are you like dude they were just
sitting
waiting like [__] Sheepdogs just
trying to like you know sit back like
stand there because all the stores all
the restaurants were complaining because
there were so many people outside after
Jersey mice came and thanked us because
they sold out of everything so [__]
fast they had to go buy more bread at a
different store
the Mexican restaurant down the street
said they sold so much [__] they started
giving away free [__] to everyone in
line to say thank you bam just
just
thank you stimulating your town like
we're not
we're not sitting there blowing joints
we're not sitting there I didn't even
smoke
yeah you know so Dallas was
an event at the smoke shop was enough to
piss them off yes
yeah they kept sir I just talked to
every family the cops down they're like
bro
yeah they're circling they're just keep
going back and forth they probably [__]
with people just coming out of there
regularly well what they started doing
when nobody was doing anything wrong
they started telling people
because they started going and running
everyone's tag like no that guy's got a
ticket toe one guy's in the line's like
I just got told I go shut the [__] up
because
I guess I didn't get my [__] tags and
another guy was like dude
my car payment was two days ago I just
got [__] repoed some guy got his
[__] Honda repoed in line God damn
he's like dude I lived down the street I
didn't I forgot to pay my [__] and they
repo my [__] car he got the call and
everything
there's nothing he could do about it
it's like dude I forgot to pay my
[__] car payment I got repoed they're
really calling in anything they can do
they were not [__] happy Rosie told
me after they tried to take me out to
question me and get my hold my ID
you know you suck my dick bro you're not
getting my ID let's reach my pocket and
I'll punch you in the face nah dude
um I know nothing about these nothing
about this stuff
so the whole time I'm just you know
doing it doing the meet and greet 13
hours meet and greet to the last human
being walked out
it was epic it was so awesome like it
was very cool
because I always think like you remember
the Merced meet me I'm like
people show up yeah there was a
there wasn't always
and Indiana showed me like whoa people
will show up this was bigger than
Indiana
I couldn't even imagine that's my life
only frame of reference for the show I
can't believe it man it went from here
you know to the back of the warehouse
laughs
five but yeah Loop it Loop it Loop it it
would wrap this entire [__] block
crazy wow whoa wild dude
anyway Dallas was epic as hell and at
the end it was like 30 minutes out at
the end the owner has the Maybach
and I finally got to see one in person I
got to ride in it so I finally like oh
yeah I love this car I still haven't got
to see my car I don't even touched one
so I got to ride in one but oh
oh what'd you think oh my God it lays
back the seat you were in the back yeah
the seat goes it's like one of those
pods in first class right yeah I dude I
couldn't believe it
epic epic as hell I met I met uh you're
in the chat Zay z-a-l-o-n zaylon's in
there I saw you I saw Jonathan B and
Houston I'll get into Houston
um
what was it Colton Hodges saw Colton
hudges too yeah you saw a bunch of
people from the chat man it was sick as
hell and then um
boom Oh halfway through the meet and
greet in Dallas John gotta call because
John dope is his wife's pregnant
and their daughter caught the crazy flu
of some kind
and then she's like uh she has 105 or
whatever I'm not gonna get too into it
she was super sick John literally left
in the middle of the meet and greet and
flew home it was wild dude so we're like
we were like okay
let's make it work because John was like
to help him with the thing and then the
shout out to everybody at skyrise they
just stepped up and helped it was
awesome dude it was seriously
everything worked out perfectly his
daughter's okay she's fine now she's
fine you know she's little so they were
freaking out so
um
so he had to dip out I just bounced dude
so now you got really everybody just
kind of even more so
in your face and because he's usually
kind of there too like no no he's doing
his thing outside I don't see anybody
that came with me until the end I see
him passing Rosie's periodically give me
a water
because in the juice Vlogs he's always
like that's because he's out doing his
thing yeah I'm not with him in the Vlogs
if you notice I'm always by myself and
they explain to me what happened at like
so that came back which guy oh with the
big pissing at like a [__] clown on
the shirt what'd he do like because I
have a [__] memory that I remember
almost everybody's face
some people get back in line like you're
already in lines like all my friends
showed I'm like I remember people's
faces I almost remember everybody's name
yeah you've done it in the Vlogs yeah
I've done in the Vlog where I remember
[__] names yeah yeah I don't
know it works it takes me 15 times to
remember your name like oh no I'll go to
a restaurant hey what's your name I
[__] forgot already but these
meetings because I'm like I can't I'm
like yeah what's up what's your name
[__] yeah so um
meeting was great meet and greet was
super sick I haven't talked about it yet
but I went to the [__] podiatrist to
talk to you about it
foot doctor foot doctor
so in Miami after we were done with the
Miami meet and greet my feet hurt so
violently I told Rosie like I think my
feet are broken something's wrong I went
to the doctor both of my arches broke
both of my arches and my feet are
collapsed
so I was right my feet were broken
so after the Dallas meet and greet my
feet were cartoon
you know what I mean like they were
throbbing oh my oh my God they hurt so
bad but Rosie brought these delay
compressors and it helped thank you Rose
you just got me inside oh yes oh my God
so boom wake up go to Houston right go
to Houston mind you we smoked one joint
Two Joints with John
haven't smoked since
smoke a couple dabs no wheat I brought
hella weed I was just so exhausted I
couldn't like bring myself to go
downstairs and smoke it outside dude I
was just my feet hurt so bad
and then boom We flew to Houston
slip
woke up Houston meet and greet
I okay we got there and I'm like oh good
cool line I didn't realize it dipped
around the corner and then back I just
thought it was like that strip so when I
went in the back of the building to
bring the boxes in I go oh my God it
wraps the building
there was like 400 people in line before
we even started the first people in line
were people I met in Dallas they've been
to both shout out to your grandma for
bringing your ass she stand in line for
the whole time and drove him she was
dope she said she watched this [__] too
and uh
epic we start the meet and greet same
thing my cops really showed up like they
already came
before we even started I'll just say I
don't care there's a restaurant out
there in Houston Molina's or Molina's
the family might be great the lady have
run your [__] [__] [__] [__]
immature ass woman is probably in her
60s
wow
wow anyway yeah she were the neighbors
we offered them to cater the week can we
buy your restaurant out and you cater
everything for us they said [__] no
can we buy out your parking lot for the
day because it's Sunday so we can have
people [__] now
so she was calling the cops when people
were parking in the empty [__]
parking lot two empty school parking lot
like school-sized parking lot they
wouldn't let nobody Park in them
why because you didn't want anybody
parking in her [__] parking lot
okay so that's how it started I'm like
oh you know what it's okay don't worry
have a great day you know the the guy
Chris was owns BC Smoke Shop shout out
to BC Smoke Shop in Houston
some of the [__] coolest people ever
epic Anthony and Mimi and [__] Chris
and everybody would they're just so
they're dope as hell
anyway we get there I go through the
back I'm like whoa he's like cops
already showed up like for real
nobody's even smoking a line like what
the [__] so I'm like you know what let's
start so we start meet and greet at like
10 40 10 you know something like that we
just start going are you deep out in the
suburbs or is this actually said this is
in Houston okay this is like in in the
city the fact that there's a line
forming isn't like something super
insane
nobody brought a crowd that would wrap
the no nothing it's not that it wrapped
it's when if everyone was there at the
same time it would have been a half a
mile long it's an all-day thing the line
moves in bricks but it feels back yeah
dude I don't even like to see the end of
the line because it makes me feel bad as
[__] for the person sitting in the back
you know I don't even want to see the
LIE dude
everything's going good everything's
going great everybody's super nice super
stoked dope as hell and Rosie's periodic
Rosie's running the line Rosie's running
the line she's doing the microphone
she's handing out raffle tickets Rosie
is she hates talking to people like like
on a Minecraft she doesn't like that
[__] she's always talking to people but
not like hey Rosie did the whole damn
thing shout out to Chad from the dopa
shop too I'm seed yes and also Hawk the
guy you helped uh you had shot the
[__] Hawk bro he vid he filmed
everything for us what a champ let's go
[__] love never more visuals on
Instagram is that it is never more
visuals [__] love this dude he's so
badass what a nice dude film both of us
both events drove to the other one he's
just sick as hell anyway he's helping
Rosie and I'm having him film people
online what's your first video ever
watched oh yeah while they're while
they're waiting in line so that's why we
started doing Raffles so people are like
damn I've been here forever oh it won
you know I just want like people I just
something something there's a food truck
there so if you're like we rented a food
they did 900 people until they ran out
of stuff so we did the food for at least
900 people today ran out of stuff
and um
everything's going great meeting a bunch
of people uh Jonathan B from the chat I
met him a big ass fool
the tallest Mexican I ever met my life
you're huge bro I look like for real
damn I've been in the NFL if I was your
high Jesus
um he's cool as hell dude super sick guy
um I met a lot of people from the
[__] chat it was mind-blowing
actually so because if they say go what
did you say your name is what's your
icon was like is it the a with just a
green like yeah like what's up Colton
like like Aiden Aiden uh uh Dominic hey
Addis here I know you're in the chat
right now from from uh Indiana
I just remember the screenshot in my
head of the picture of who I typed to
with the icon like that's how I remember
things people driving from California
because wolf drove from California to
the Dallas one because he missed the LA
one and he's like I have friends of
Dallas I'm just gonna make a weekend out
of it
all right somebody drove from Wisconsin
Jacksonville Florida North Carolina
Ohio
Minnesota this was like a global
conference right people came from Six
States away
anyway the day's going great
everything's going good I don't know any
of the [__] that's going on outside
I don't know what's happening outside
because Rosie's not telling me she's
gonna be pissed
so there's food trucks on the side of
the building and they're pissed because
nobody's buying you because we're doing
free food who cares it wasn't your
business anyway
the barbershop next door it's Sunday
Barbershop next door look it I'm glad
she didn't tell me because if she would
have told him about how much money
you're making a day
[__] off go home he kept calling the
cops because people were in front of his
building
it's a sidewalk
it's not the end of the world it's not
the end of the world the guy at Cricket
next door Cricket Wireless is [__]
ancient bro your store is gonna go under
eat a dick anyway Cricket Wireless next
door to BC Smoke Shop guy's a [__]
[__] told people don't stand next to
my son
it's a sidewalk don't stand next to my
tent like a child I didn't know this I
definitely would have [__] open Palm
smacked the [__] out of somebody went to
jail
so I'm glad she didn't tell me but the
Molina [__] kept being a [__] [__]
I'm sorry the restaurant's been there
for so long I don't want it down I don't
want to [__] their [__] up because
they're probably really nice people but
the older woman that's running it was
super rude and I always me and Rosie
haven't it sounds [__] up but every
time someone's rude to Rosie in public
and she does nothing I get mad at her
it's [__] stupid I feel like an
[__] after it I'm like I'm mad at you
because you that so but don't let people
[__] do [__] to you like it pisses me
off there's been a few times like this
dude was hella rude like where the [__]
is he like I'm I because she's super
nice so you're like who the [__] thinks
they can live now like I'm gonna kill
you just because they're I mean you
would think like yo you should be super
super nice I mean you're a [__] [__]
you know you can tell read somebody like
that person is nice but you were rude to
who oh I'm gonna pump it open Palm slap
the [__] out of you
but she's an old woman but I would
definitely
dissect her with my words like I'm good
with that not let it go I would I I'm
good with that like I
she was walking up to kids with her
[__] phone and shoving you in their
face while you're on my property like a
[__] kid
and Rosie snatched her [__] phone out
her hand and told her to get the [__]
out of there so happy and proud of her
for that dude snapped her [__] hat
snatched out her hand and told her get
the [__] out loud that was supposed to
be there where it almost fit though yeah
that's the laugh that just played oh my
God uh some dude kept trying to sell a
gun in line
she told me after and I got a bunch of
DMs like there's a dude out here trying
to sell [__] guns to us I had no idea
some random man just saw a line goes
going by this pistol what the [__] some
crackhead shot some crackhead [__] yeah
so I didn't know that apparently P not
us but the street next to us was super
blocked and the guy was screaming at the
line because he thought it was their
cars
and his movers left but he was calling
his movers [__] and they quit on him
and then he asked us to reimburse him
for his [__] move
[Laughter]
then the guy in a blue car got stuck and
was almost gonna fight the U-Haul Guy
this is all secondhand I'm getting was
gonna fight him
and he was so mad that he had to back up
that I guess he whipped through next to
the line almost hit Chad our guy almost
hit two other people and those people
dm'd me like dude there's a guy out here
I almost got [__] ran over I guess he
whipped down that little side street
going like 50 or 60 with all those
people standing there
damn because he was embarrassed that he
had to move back anyway that guy also
has probably a [__] life so just let it
go
um
so people parked in the back parking lot
they didn't know they're not allowed to
so she parked a truck to block him in
the restaurant lady Rosie she kept
coming back and forth so Rosie kept
telling me get the [__] out of there
like leave these people the [__] alone
we're not on your property and they went
into the restaurant to like all right
her and Chris's wife was like let's go
have a drink with this lady
she probably sees a bunch of dudes just
feels a little threat and he's like
let's go talk to her we're girls like
let's go talk they went in there not a
[__] person in the restaurant nobody
in the restaurant
yeah so there's no customers and she's
acting like a [__] [__] wouldn't we
offered to pay it
we offered to pay for anything we if
we're in your apartment can we pay like
as we were customers
she just she didn't even know what I did
she just didn't want people around
I don't understand I really really
really really hope she was just having a
horrible day because a person like that
sounds like a [__] Disney villain
yeah I mean Jesus Christ oh but then
again like I'm glad she didn't tell me
because I would have lost my [__]
politely and made her probably feel so
stupid she went home well I mean the
host of the event isn't supposed to be
managing all the million things going
wrong or whatever somebody's trying to
do some [__] to the people outside
that came to see me I'm a [__] a little
man
to
yeah and then some do try to cut the
line and told Rosie I'll pay for it he's
like who is here he must be somebody I'm
gonna take a picture with him some hood
ass fool and Rosie told me get the [__]
out he can't do it he's like no I can
pay for anything and then he's like who
the [__] are you and then I guess
everyone was like who the [__] are you
they had Rosie's back yeah of course
they don't realize that you could stop
by 600 people don't do this if there's
ever a time to back the [__] up it's the
time that there's an army you know and
Chad is six six
got that on camera you got that on
camera good good I guess he said it's
not La everything's for sale and then
Rosie said you could buy the back of the
line and the guy got so pissed and left
but I'm so happy she told people to eat
it yeah
oh I [__] feel so much better knowing
that that happened anyway cops kept
coming back it came five times after the
fifth time they said it's now a
disturbance you're just now disturbing
the piece if I get this many calls even
though nobody was
doing anything you can call to serve the
piece on a football game every day then
a soccer practice a [__] basketball
game
the [__] the ball's bouncing that's loud
they weren't even making noise when we
gave out raffle tickets
that's it yeah
so somebody just didn't like it shout
out to AutoZone for letting people use
the bathroom
if you're in Houston go to the AutoZone
by BC Smoke Shop and buy your [__]
oil there right super nice thank you for
letting people actually use the bathroom
that was awesome of you it's basically
it's like today's different from regular
days I don't like it yeah dude and it
just made me upset because like we
smiled said hello offered to be forever
pay you
as if you had business but you didn't
have the business
I'll have some nice little Yelp thing on
there but I didn't say anything about
the food because I didn't try it I said
although this is not about food you know
like I was pissed dude like how can you
be so rude especially be rude to like
um get mad about it um anyway the cops
kept coming back and they said we're
shutting your whole event down at eight
o'clock it's done as soon as this
business is closed you're closed
we were there till 1 15. to eat a dick
so this is where it gets really bad and
this is where I need to talk to the
camera you guys ready I um
Rosie tells me this time's flying by I
don't know what time it is look at my
phone at six like we're shutting down at
eight and there's still about 200 people
outside
like okay we're at hour nine or ten
there's no way I'm shutting down it's
not gonna happen
so Rosie Googled a park that was two
blocks away what we were going to do is
shut down at eight walk with everybody
like an assembly from school and walk to
the park and finish the meet and greet I
don't give a [__]
so at six o'clock we had to put a sign
at the end of the building any new
people coming after six or seven o'clock
please meet at the park like hey we
can't keep you here the cop says at
eight o'clock whoever's in the last line
is the last of the line
they were shutting us down
I'm just like hearing it like okay we'll
figure it out and I'm just trying to
like yo what's up man I'm just like I
I'm not you know what I'm saying like
I'm still in talking mode I'm hearing
talking oh sorry
eight o'clock all right all right and go
back to it because I'm you know what I'm
saying yeah so we're going through the
night and Rosie's like there's like 15
people that had to go to the park
I'm like [__] okay [__] and then she
tells me the cops kicked everybody out
of the park
it's a park
to sit at and they kicked him out of the
park because they knew where they were
from from our thing they must have just
like followed them over there
so they kicked everybody out of the park
I don't know what's happening I'm still
talking to people
and Rosie's like yo we have to go on
live and talk to like there's like about
15 people that couldn't come in I was
like [__] dudes no shove everyone in the
building so they can't say you can shut
us down this is our [__] property get
the [__] out of the store so everyone
crowded in as much as they could and
that was the last person they closed the
door
right so we put the sign outside hey so
sorry but after you know the shuttle's
down for the the
city ordinance or some [__] it's
eight o'clock it's not even anyway
we're doing our thing we're talking
everybody
and then I find out it's like 60 people
what's up
not the amount of people it's the fact
that
some people got there at seven
and we're told to leave
because the fools were outside telling
them like no it's over you have to go
you can't be here
so I kept thinking like damn I remember
when I was a little kid and fools be
like yo you're not playing get the [__]
out of here you're a [__] fat kid
like [__] you get out of here like I
remember the feeling like damn walking
away like remember my [__]
Travis Barker story right exactly like
oh bro that [__] was so like it's like
it's not it's like an embarrassment but
more of like damn I hurt my feelings
[__] yeah how come I can't [__] be
here that's how I felt as a kid and I
just started thinking like [__] dude I
hope there's not like a
like anti-socialized dude out there that
just got turned and he's never going to
nothing again in his life you know what
I mean like this is the first thing he's
ever like uh this this dude's like he'll
talk to me and be cool and then they get
turned away so I felt like a [__]
bully almost even though it's not my
[__] fault just like feeling like oh
damn that's the feeling I gave somebody
that's whack as hell
and then she like broke my [__] heart
dude I was crying I was pissed off
but she waited to tell me at the hotel
because she knew it was gonna be [__]
furious
so right now I'm trying to find everyone
in the DMS and emails I got like 40
people so far
it's so [__] hard to figure out like
yo were you really there
because don't just try to [__] play
him like yeah I was there
because I had a few people do that
already this much about it it's just a
lot dude it's like [__] man
somebody told me they flew in from New
Mexico landed at six walked up and got
turned away hmm
that's not that's right bro yeah that's
not cool at all just for the sake of
[__] with them basically we stayed
till one third one fifteen I would have
stayed till four I don't give a [__] we
could have saw everybody with another
two hours
but they were being [__] [__] man
I don't even get it man I I it really
like
it bugs me so [__] bad that people
those even if they don't like weed
it's still like
you see how happy everyone is like
waiting outside like
waiting in the line and they're stoked
this must be something positive this
must be something cool look how many
[__] people are here yeah so it
really just it really bugged me
and like hurt my [__] feelings
knowing that like damn there's some
fools out there that are probably almost
crying
you know what I'm saying
so I'm I'm going I'm finding them
there's so many [__] DMs I already
had a few fools trying to [__] play
me yeah that really pissed me off dude I
was there bro I'm a big fan I I come on
man I can't even make and I look
[__] in another state that day
on a story that pissed me the [__] off
dude
Phil's trying to play me like that that
really bugged me anyway at the time this
comes out I've already talked to every
single person that was not there that
got turned away so don't hit me up again
don't try to play me don't try to
[__] scam me
done by the time this video is out I
have already talked to every single one
of you and sent you something some it's
push trees and dope is Jefferson
something I don't give a [__] I want you
to cause it's you know I mean it's worth
it's worth uh
not being upset about yeah like even if
they're like oh I still would rather
meet you like in my head I'm like but I
did try yeah yeah I [__] tried like I
sent you some [__]
not the DM like I'm gonna send them like
sign poster because I'll get more
posters or something and like a shirt or
[__] pen or edible
you know what I'm saying like something
they're like damn oh okay sick yeah and
it won't be the last time either yeah
you know what I'm saying so that is the
only thing that bugs me it pissed me off
it's been like three days I'm so pissed
off about it
but I'm not thinking about it as much as
I was because I'm like
Foster's different they're there they're
[__] just trying to be all up in your
lives the show's different I mean it's
not like a personal thing it's just what
they do in States like that they [__]
they're just in your [__] they're
annoying it's like a huge difference so
dumb dude I felt that as soon as I never
even got pulled over or nothing I just
felt that from them even just being
there [__] just oh you guys are just
trying to suck money out of the people
that you're supposed to be protecting I
get you about 15 people told me in the
DM I showed up saw all the cops out
there and I left I'm a felony probation
if anybody smoke a weed around me they
wrote my name I go to jail
the fear that you can't even stand in a
line because of somebody else is doing
is [__] up I had so many people hit me
up and tell me that like yo my family
probation or like I'm on parole I'm on
probation like I cannot
be in that line if those cops are there
he's like I know Houston they're gonna
[__] run me they're gonna run money
they're gonna run my place they're gonna
do this like they weren't wrong that's
what they're doing in Dallas dude just
trying to see if they can [__] take
anybody out
yeah Footloose for weed
but this is some gorilla [__] that
you're doing like we said going out and
just humaning as you said that I read
the word girl
so next time we come through these
cities it's going to be podcasting yeah
it's going to be in the form of a live
podcast at a venue and there will be no
cops [__] with it nothing completely
legitimized exactly
[__] [__] and it might be two
nights it might be four shows and two
nights because you know you won't have
to sit there for [__] six hours until
the shortest weight was five and a half
in Dallas and
seven hours in Houston shout out to
everybody right now I had about 10
people say they had to leave because
they had to go to work I felt that I
didn't feel as bad because I cannot
control that but I still feel like damn
I they're on my list too like yo I got
you don't trip but it's like [__] and
like [__] Wheezy I told you from the
chat bro I just told Marty about you
from the live chat he showed up and he
couldn't even get in because he had to
go
you're in the live chat all the [__]
time and you can't even be oh man it
just bugged me like knowing like
hey [__] I would have stayed all
day bro I would have slept in the
morning like
we'll figure it out but shout out to
Smurf holes I'll just say that real
quick this dude was super nice
dude so we'll smoke this right here I
told you I'd smoke a man
appreciate you
yeah all in all it was a success I mean
you met there was more people than ever
we met almost 3 000 people one percent
that probably couldn't see you in [__]
uh we're gonna you know make that right
but it was good everybody was cool
everybody brought Good Vibes and [__]
every single person they went for the
community across the world a bunch of
wild ass names I asked you know I asked
everybody their name
um
a lot of the a lot of you fools in Texas
your Mexican food's got a lot of the
same names I'm just gonna say that right
now I said hey what's up one like 700
times in a row like oh what's up like
all right well sick and I was like damn
there's a lot of Wands and Carlos is out
here holy [__]
oh man I told you about the conundrum of
a dude that I met the other day right
no black dude with dreads oh yeah all
right go this dude is running the Best
Buy
black dude with dreads his name Jesus
but he's like Jamaican but he's got a
full British accent oh [__]
yeah that's like those books remember
the books that had three slots and they
had dinosaurs you can change the one
part of the body that's what they did
when they made him
he was killing it he was running [__]
Jamaican it took me a second Jesus name
Jesus with their English accent he was
like like really saying British [__] too
like not slimy yeah like really laying
into it bro
yeah sorry what were we talking about oh
yeah everybody's gone yeah what I met a
dude named justice that was epic I asked
everybody a lot of people had wild names
like what do your parents do like
[__] acid but bet you they were on
acid I had a lot of people like Aaron
roach I met Aaron roach that's your real
name bro
a sick ass name
yes the household
Crossing what are we at right now
um 52. oh all right all right it's the
season finale we're just
we literally went to our spot
and always we explained that never mind
so we just brought this thing in we're
like dude let's knock out season two
we're wearing our vintage Throwbacks for
the last episode of the season with the
table wild man got a lot of great laughs
up in this one hooker right here a lot
of good [__] right here that's crazy
so wild to think about
that we're just getting started too
that's the other thing like we're gonna
look back barely on a couple episodes
we've had like 60 people in here only
yeah we're gonna look back like wow that
little bit of time before season three
remember those couple episodes we did in
the warehouse
[__] is legendary though thanks guys
just for being able to make this
possible make everything possible [__]
is really all coming together in
fruition and [__] dude
it's just wild thank you guys for
everything
um
so yeah the meet and greet went well oh
what am I doing out here
a big news me and Rosie are moving this
weekend all right finally got it dude we
uh
I'm so stoked
there you go there you go nice nice uh
thing oh I got your note by the way
I got this in Texas I didn't I I didn't
fly back with it I threw it as far as I
could like Uncle Rico way over the
mountains
made it to La all right I swear it
didn't fly with it prove it
um here we go got your note appreciate
that this right here pixie stick this is
all
[__] looks expansive yeah it does
oh child proof how about this [__] with
the bathing ape Blue urban camo [__]
with the HS on the tip it's dope dude
also everyone wants Marty to be at these
meet and greets bro oh my God people
would not where's Mark I told you I
signed a lot of things like can you sign
it Marty didn't make it because he
didn't show up like bro he's every time
it's like he's got three children and
he's working that's my I say everything
like we know we know but like yeah one
day we will guys yeah I'll be uh man I
would love to be there but I'm [__]
you're [__] woman you do the super
commercial yeah literally you were doing
big huge awesome things outside of that
I'm even I'm holding on the fort with
all the edits and [__] yeah that you got
a new backyard coming in yeah I mean
but now that we're handing over the
podcast and [__] I'm about to get my you
know I just made my new schedule and
we're about to really do this [__] full
time so you know I will be around we
will be doing this podcast tour this
[__] we'll be going crazy look what it
says Marty
hold on
Hot Box me
instructions the instructions just say
hot box me so ready comes in the paper
man
it looks like a regular rapper look
Rosie
remember Josh remember he made the he
rolled the hash flat the push tree's
house
and then we've rolled it with weed it's
in one of our old Vlogs like 2014. he's
like this is called a hash stick I kind
of just started doing it it's a company
that does it look
there's no paper Ralph there's no paper
it's all hash as the paper
so we're about to smoke keep it keep it
so I'll light this up
so
yeah
so I just I got oh also I got your
lyrical lemonade joint don't think I
forgot oh I like we got it yeah no the
lyric eliminates uh a music label uh
Cole Bennett he's uh he does music
videos he has a lyrical lemonade paper
collab with raw and
um ah you had a King Palm shirt on I'm
sorry I don't remember your name exactly
but you brought your brother I believe
long hair could look at ratchet man
kinda you gave me the lyrical lemonade
Joe I appreciate you
um also some fools get you know who you
are I don't say your name but thank you
for the shrooms I could not bring them
on the plane I had to give them to
somebody at the shop
sorry
like regular actual shrooms regular
shrooms
and uh we gotta obviously address the
elephant in the room what
the bills yes
[Music]
I had to help people DM me check on
Marty bro
check up on them I got what happened all
the bills
hey it's okay
you guys had a bad year in Buffalo this
year man it's okay next year will be
coming God damn next year will be good
yeah shout out to Buffalo we never
really addressed it Buffalo's had one of
the most tragic years a [__] City can
have it was just so extra and my heart
goes out to everybody affected by all
the different tragedies that went down
this year dude
but uh so much yeah it was a lot I would
a Super Bowl would have been [__]
fabulous but
at the end of the day I mean we're just
too inconsistent and that's just the
reality of it
you know nobody's asking for my opinion
but we [__] nobody's asking for my
opinion we play like a Super Bowl team
in small spurts yeah if we could only do
it I mean the Bengals did it all game
long against us they didn't stop they
impose their weapons they [__] first
down after first down after first down
they beat us by 17 it should have been
way more we got you know Josh Allen
always has to come back and be such a
goddamn hero for us to win crawl and
scratch out of these
holes we put ourselves in but he's not
wildly inconsistent although he is a
[__] hero and he is great but first
he was the laser and then he was the
runner and then he stopped doing both
really
and then he started throwing picks and
then he got hurt and that's just like
somewhere we lost our [__] Mojo and
our confidence and dig stopped getting
looks God knows Singletary wasn't
running for much we had role players
step up we [__] lost uh
we lost um
we'll see you know two of them bad thing
that ever happened
Jesus Christ
there's a runner then he stopped we had
people step up we had a guy die in the
field he came back that was wild like
shout out to Demar Hamlin
those conspiracies theories I already
seen them yeah oh uh it did look weird
how they had it all like covertly come
into the arena are you ready I'm just
gonna give my opinion I believe that
theory that that wasn't him at the game
but why are you ready you're the NFL you
know what
NFL mic
I'm just gonna say my opinion real quick
and we'll go crazy
if you're making shirts of somebody and
you're promoting them so crazy and
you're making shirts get well better get
get soon you're gonna show their face I
mean he's you're not gonna hide their
face yeah you're not gonna only shoot
from the side
yeah you're not gonna put glasses on in
on in the field
I'm sorry bro they didn't bring him on
the field right like no when he's in the
cart go into the yeah yeah but I'm
saying they didn't bring him on the
field I didn't see the very beginning of
the game and this is this is look this
is all speculation because I saw the
conspiracy thing I went
hmm
if right right now if that's a heart
soul or your team right now literally
the heart of your team you're gonna show
his face let everybody know he's good
and now you can prosper and do anything
I mean he's on social media I can be on
social media right now while I'm talking
somebody running it for everybody no but
I'm saying like his face and [__] oh
really yeah like there's pictures of him
and his love for Demar shirts and the
hospital bed pictures I don't care about
I want to see video you can edit me
right now
okay that's a fair point I was just
gonna say man I know a lot of very good
Photoshop people I don't give a [__] as
sad as hell
I'm only saying it because I did see the
conspiracy yeah
that's a pretty cool from the side like
that odd very odd see when I saw him
pull up in the little uh buggy and [__]
in my mind I was like damn when they
bring that [__] out in the field
it is gonna go crazy at the beginning of
the game I just assumed they did
oh no but to mask somebody up glasses
hoodie hat beanie
that's what you do when you're on the
run it doesn't to hide yourself shoot
them through the door through the door
only the shot of him getting out and he
walked in like like Michael Jackson
no hell no bro something made me think
hmm also they brought Marv Levy out to
give us I don't know the man did his
heart is like [__] with I have no idea
I get your hearts [__] with not your
face if you're posting on social media
why can't you post show your face to the
fans that want to see and like love and
break down and cry and be happy and
stoked and hype your team up to win this
[__] game
I don't know Marty
I have no idea I don't know I'll just
say that odd I'm not saying it's true
but odd that's all weird yeah Beauty
triangle Theory I could be real good now
if they yeah if they didn't bring them
out and they didn't interview him or
anything like if he's at the game that
means he's gonna be super cleared to be
like exactly
you're cleared to be out if you're at a
football game you're cleared to be out
it means you can talk
that's all I'm saying either way I'm not
going to look this up and keep this
mysterious yeah I'll keep it mysterious
you let us know you tell us what the
[__] is going on NFL also
we don't care don't be mad at us
DraftKings
thank you for sponsoring the episode NFL
let us talk about conspiracies
hey I don't care the podcast talk about
it it's fine but yeah I thought it was
crazy I saw that thing I'm like huh
people go wild people just make either
you may [__] up made it look real good
or what have they showed me only the
clips that they didn't show his face
they did show his face there's always
there's always things you could do that
make people think something else so I'm
just giving our opinions it's fun it's
fun to talk about as a guy that did face
swaps from [__] Photoshop for [__]
10 years thank you thank you you can
make me look like Mario Lopez's son
right now
I have I made the Honor graphic thank
you
Amber
I was all fake buff these things are
awesome they're pretty much
so
so yeah I repeat to our [__]
season damn
also we're off track
we moved
we never even said anything it's like we
move and then we just start going
[__] talking about this
Rosie and I are finally moving
that's it I can't say anything else
about the apartment I should have diesel
it's not an apartment know about the
place we're leaving it was great oh yeah
it was great I just don't want to live
in an apartment anymore we found a house
but we did find a GTA house I will admit
I will say I still hasn't hit me yet
when I walk in
when the right one opened the door with
my own key is when all like
oh this is our house
guys
finally
all the I can't even believe it man and
the thing is when they're doing I need
to do this and you just paying them you
need your credit and I'm like
I have this I got it I got it I don't
have to pay my friend to make fake bank
statements not that I'm saying I ever
did that
but I'll let you know
there's a plethora of them all right but
yeah I've uh I may or may not have to do
some fake bank statements in my whole
life
they're cheap
but people do it so cheap
yeah so I didn't have to fake anything I
had to fake stubs I had to document [__]
yeah this is really me doing this real
yeah and there was no doubt in my mind
that we're getting it like yeah I want
this place
I was like oh that was my [__] that
was my Get Rich or Die Tryin moment you
want this car
dropping it and leave
finally it happened
finally [__] happened so excited
this thing's kind of falling apart I
gotcha dude
um so yeah the house guys is a GTA it's
a Grand Theft Auto does it have a
backyard
I didn't see
diesel dumb question is that a fool no
the other house the exact same layout
did have a pool but it was gonna take
three months to be done I'm like oh yeah
I don't want fools in my backyard for
three months I smoke joints at all is
there neighbors like close by or not
yeah it's a it's a gated it's a gated
like Community thing
um but
oh God this is out it's a gated
community
it's essentially
right next to Calabasas
so I'm kind of farther but it's right
now it's like right next to it
and uh so what's going on is
wait where you going
talk into that one oh this one did
hi hello how you doing well Marty's
doing this for the last time
because now we have people that do the
cameras and we met them today
guys there's a bunch of the camp they're
one camera is equal to the studio
every single light pole every pole
everything the labor that camera the
lens that camera that camera that camera
this board your computer is one of their
cameras
I'm so excited guys they did like a
little sit-in test today to look at it
you know when you see interview shows
and there's like depth in the back
that's what our new [__] looks like I
can't wait to show you guys like
me and Marty just started doing this to
see if we can get it done we had fun the
whole time
and here we are
all right so a lot of people hold on
before I take it away from talk about
the house
every single person that I talk to for
all you out there I told Marty every
single one of your stories about what
you do now
and people were talking about it was
this episode that you said this or this
episode Marty said something he said
this and I thought maybe I can do that
so I got my license and then I got my
LLC and then I got this and another
dude's like yo I'm a district manager
distribution now I do this you just told
me I was I was I was lazy I'm gonna be
honest I was lazy and I kept watching
you guys and thought damn I'm the guy
they're talking to I'm the guy they're
yelling at saying stop being a lazy
[__] and get the [__] up
so you know what I mean that that's and
the Phil told me that I don't know what
episode because we say it every episode
but he's like I heard that too many
[__] times from you guys and I just
got up his [__] wife started tearing
she's like he he really is doing so much
better like it was it was
Epic
so [__] cool to see these things the
clothing company there was four a group
of four homies they're all 16 and one
was 17 they all had a clothing company
and they gave me a sick ass one with the
skull I got it in Dallas with the pr
that [__] sick and shout out to that
full uh the the Brand's called Maniac I
believe
sick as hell I have the shirt you're
painting thank you for the canvas it's
getting shipped right now from Houston
it was too big for my suitcase dude and
there was no way in [__] hell I was
leaving it so it's on the way thank you
very much
um shout out for the Mike Tyson glove
someone gave me an autographed Tyson
glove mic I can't take this it's like
nah I run I do Collectibles I'm like oh
so this is like your thing okay thank
you man I'll take that because I'm like
no I can't take this
he's like he's gonna be your co-worker
right like yeah
whoa yeah he's about to be that's crazy
um
and then
oh yeah so on the other side of the wall
in the non-smoking section at our new
studio is Tony Hawk and Jason Ellis
I'm the shortest person in the building
I just want to say that put that out
there now
Tyson's taller than me Matt Barnes is
taller than Stephen Jackson uh you uh
Tony Hawk
Jason Ellis and I will officially say
I'm the highest in the building though
so that's cool maybe not maybe Marty
Marty smokes no Marty Marty's Beast the
[__] out of bowls bro you guys gotta see
the way Marty smokes the bowls anytime I
see the camera up I'm like oh he's about
to rip that [__] Marty's the type of
dude that will rip it
take a second
like that was so still you don't give a
[__] whoa like your lungs are strong you
don't go back for that second rip hell
no you know how many times if I don't
get the bowl pulled and it sticks I will
take it off but I'm saying you do the
first slow this [__] out I know you I'm
saying I know that's your move but you
do the first thing there's still it's
still kind of on fire
oh I rip all bowls in one breath
because I hate stale bowls that's why I
take huge risks because I'm like I can't
take that yeah
see to me I could never waste um no I
don't I don't I don't waste it you just
clear the whole thing in one shot all
the time yeah but I'm saying like say I
clear the whole thing and it's milked
it's milked it's milked and the bowl
gets stuck and doesn't come out yeah and
if it's more than a second and a half oh
stop take the bowl out and I'll blow the
smoke out I will not smoke that [__]
because I know what it's gonna taste
like I know how I'm gonna feel it gives
me a weird headache right here I don't
know what it is about still smoke I can
taste it on my teeth yeah I'm just
starting to not love that either yeah I
just can't do it anymore after after
years and years and years of wound I
can't wait it like waste it you're alone
yeah I've kind of scaled back a little
bit now that you blessed me with the
[__] my little
uh jars and [__] like this quality it's
like I'm just a little bit nice little
hair just hit the hemp Wick it's like
it's better yeah it's like sauteing
instead of like yo put that [__] in the
microwave like nah take your time yeah
it'll be better for you and better so
and dope yeah that [__] is cool yeah
it's cool man a little little your
little setup yeah it's different and
soon Emmy's gonna not be a little kid
running around should be at school and
you're gonna be able to like oh I can
smoke a bowl I have to worry about huh
what did she do
bro Marty answered his face time
and then out the corner I see Emery and
you guys know we talked about me all the
time he's a little daughter
she just looks at me
tongue out she does and she's like
laughing and just puts her leg over her
head
huh
like
oh good job that's like oh I can't do
that dude little kids are so [__]
hilarious to like make them feel like
they're the coolest person ever but oh
you can do that
yo she's the funniest little girl I
might have ever come across John's
daughter Sophia she's up there yeah you
guys might be tied but I know Emmy so
much more because he FaceTime so much
yeah and oh my god
dude when uh Julian was Frankenstein and
big daddy that's right right now exactly
that is that's
perfect
that is perfect he's so [__] funny
she's funny dude
damn but uh well we're getting our
[__] pool put in right now right our
backyard looks like sorry
a water zone right now your backyard
looks like a third world country it
really does there's dirt everywhere
planted on the ground and there's stuff
mixed with wires the pool workers keep
bumping into my [__] barn and [__]
out there do they you leave it outside
yeah yeah I'm about to start 20. I'm
covering it and [__]
yeah yeah that [__] is funny to me I
hear him laughing
you're making me Spanish
you know all this is going on just
outside my door constantly I'm sitting
here editing looking at these dudes
working and they're hearing the videos
too I'm at it in the rig video all
they're hearing is
come on Mom smoke that for real and I'm
like I think that shit's funny it is
funny
they probably don't get that we got the
sheriff next door I got all these
workers going on you do got the sheriff
next door this [__] is funny to me did
you ever think you'd be
building my own pool in my own house hi
Sheriff
that's something you can't do in New
York yeah that's a difference it's a
different Beast me like he loves us oh
yeah you're the [__] you guys are the
picture perfect family yeah he's like
your guys are [__] not playing around
with this house like you're making me
have pressure on my [__] like we've been
waiting 20 years to do all this [__]
yeah
never did I think like the tables would
turn like this dude it's crazy I feel my
neighbors across my yo what do you guys
do and then I thought oh yeah
we're not in a trap neighborhood you
know because every time people in this
neighborhood no they like the wildest
cars are across the street I'm like whoa
what do you guys selling I think oh yeah
we're in this place you have a nice
house okay you're just falling you
belong here never mind because I that I
still have that thing in my head of like
damn what does this [__] do [__]
I don't say where we are but our
neighbors are crap oh God our neighbors
hopefully you guys don't watch a show
but I know what you guys are doing bro
it's good gods are shipping
it's comical
at some point I'm like
you guys don't even hide it you guys are
all
every one of you is pulling up in 400
yeah are we filming a movie here is
that video out there like Dan the first
Maybach I ever saw the trucks that
bounced was my neighbor
all these young ass fools looking at us
as
we're your neighbors [__] it's
been two years stop staring at me but
they don't hide it but anyway my new
neighbors I looked and I went what do
you do what do you sell oh that's when I
came to the realization of like
Rancho Cucamonga and I bought this
[__] cash I feel like Uncle
Elroy but I'm renting I'm renting the
house I didn't buy the house yet that's
how I feel like wow
Sachi that's how I feel man my neighbors
oh I couldn't believe I was like damn I
had to calling in I got the [__]
Phantom and I was like damn they got the
road the Brabus man you got to sit on
1.3 right there oh my God just in the
parking lot just in the driveway not
even in the garage they just those are
the cars outside yeah
yeah are you kidding me
and guess what else you have to be very
You're gonna laugh at this
we moved into this community right
the day before I moved I mean the day
before I went to Texas John also moved
he John dope has got a new spot
my new spot is two blocks from away from
John
I tell you that oh yeah you did yeah
that's crazy he's from that's a done
deal to the end of the block and halfway
back that's it he's doubt if I really
put my leg into it I can throw a
baseball in three throws to his house
hmm
I know exactly what you mean
what
wait
we're gonna take the whole neighborhood
let's all like his brother's looking for
a spot and Toes looking for a spot now
too and Tony's looking for a spot like
wait
if we all live into a block of each
other we're gonna become billionaires
this is thank you there's like
the thing is the people I hang out with
it's never like that fool got a new
thing like damn this [__] yeah he's
always trying to advice no it's not it's
always [__] yeah it's like that you
already know you know them it's more
like
good [__] it's like everybody's stoked
for each because support yeah bro like
you want everybody to they're your
homies yeah well that's one of those
things where it's like they say like
you're kind of the average of like your
five friends you're around the most and
it's like that's but in a good way and
usually people say that like in a bad
way but and it's not like oh holy we
only think about rich friend like no
what the [__]
you know who I am I just got enough
money to buy a car like [__] you I'm
trying I'm trying not even like
financially but just as a member that's
what I'm saying like I have a homies if
I go two years ago I I couldn't buy that
and they're in that position and I'm
like no
we need to do something we can all like
that's why we started with our homies
we're starting this with our friend like
we can all do something in some way
if I'm doing this you can do it too with
because you're not doing a show you know
you're not making content like you have
the time to crush [__] and that's like
the mindset we're trying to get with
everybody that I [__] care about yeah
100 it's crazy to watch it's gonna be so
sick dude I can't wait man it's like a
branch exactly yeah but I'm very happy
that we're moving I can uh
you saw the spot I can't wait to move in
Dude Looks Like Gordon Bombay's house
when he what's that and Mighty Ducks too
[Laughter]
when he blew up and he [__] got his
deals
it was crazy
I don't know I thought of George
Hamilton when you said like that guy
with a tan but I did not know what you
were saying I'm excited dude I can I can
officially fly a drone in the living
room
um
that's your [__] nobody can [__] with
you like as long as a landlord is cool
bitching at you and [__] you drive right
into the [__] garage get out with
your groceries you're in the kitchen
I'm so excited it's gonna be so cool man
I'm
I'm stoked I've never had stairs before
um
stairs except up to my apartment door
yeah you guys can spread out they're
relaxed steps I looked the first thing I
walked in like huge living room there's
space under the stairs
I'm gonna lay right there for real I'm
gonna put a day bed under the stairs and
just smoke weed under the stairs
oh it's epic dude maybe even like a
little fake clouds they're gonna lay
under the stairs nice fish tank or
something something cool no I don't want
fish today I feel bad for the fish all
right they can't go nowhere
I feel I may feel so pissed like damn
for that whole living room I gotta stay
over here
think of that [__] yeah like damn you
stare [__] [__] where you live
oh damn
fish are in prison I feel bad man yeah
Jesus sorry I don't have a bunch of
people just looked at their fish tank
God damn it I thought I was a good yeah
like I thought I was doing good [__]
like no he's [__] in his food You're
just showing off all your freedom to him
though yeah he has to pick and choose
what [__] and food at the top
thank God think of that all right next
time you kidnap the thing
all right here we go
there was no I was going nowhere with
that anyway we're moving damn this show
this is so fun that we get to do this
thank you guys for being along it's
coming along for the ride everybody that
came to the meet and greet I told you if
we saw 1500 people that day
1481 said the podcast the first thing
you said the [__] podcast everyone
that's like yo I put my earbuds in I
guess so many people's jobs by what they
said like you put my earbuds so you were
stuck you're doing overnight stocking
what the [__] am I I'll see you work at
Amazon
I got if there was if I guess at 20
times I got like 16 times like damn I
can tell just by what you do about your
truck driver
he's like so you know I just put it on
like so you drive for work right you're
a truck driver
yeah we're from Amazon I'm like oh damn
everybody was [__] Amazon Jesus
Christ stop selling my [__]
Amazon keeps taking push trees Prince
and selling them they keep them giving
them assists and they won't stop I keep
supporting you every week my buying [__]
from you and you're
stealing from me you're stealing from me
putting push tree [__] on rolling trays
now and selling it
Jeff Bezos we're gonna arm wrestle
despite all the flagging and Reporting
and all that stuff and I think it's
crazy huh
um anyway yeah we're moving we're moving
two blocks away from John it's about to
be Craig and DayDay I'm very excited
Rancho Cucamonga style
um we already decided we're gonna get
golf carts we have to drive our car back
and forth like oh down the sidewalk bam
pull up to his front door oh my God it's
gonna be so bad dude I can already see
this I'm excited
um but yeah we move in a couple days by
the time this comes out I'll be moved
crazy Stoke what a week what a week God
damn season three season three then I'll
go to Vegas I'm going to Vegas for a day
and a half
[Music]
um in February I forgot to put that on
the calendar but it's not a film day so
we're fine but yeah I'm going to Vegas
and then for a day and a half I'll be
out there at Champs
if you're at Champs come say hi it's a
wholesalers thing so nice I might not
see everybody yeah yeah so we're gonna
get moved in we're gonna get these new
bookings booked oh we're rolling a bunch
of new sponsors we're gonna get this new
clothing line guys
go ahead and check out all the smokes
[__] clothing shop if you see Isaac's
shirt today yes our shit's gonna look
like that [__] is a real all the smokes
merch is so it it makes me go damn push
tree
it's a podcast merch [__] that's a sick
Jack I got sweat suits and [__] it makes
not the bad ways makes me want to like
do whoa I gotta do better I know like it
makes me feel like that shit's hard as
[__] this makes you start thinking
that's all but they're a podcast man
their merch is stupid right dude not to
mention they just had Will Smith on
their [__] and Magic Johnson and Steph
Curry and [__] Epic
I mean when you're NBA legends it's
really awesome when you ask other
Superstars to become on your show
because they're gonna be like yeah I
respect you and now they're gonna go the
[__] is that what's crazy yeah who said
is that it's like some like you know
some athlete it's a tall white dude some
like small Mexican guy gets high no he's
he's pretty out of shape he's trying
he's trying he's actually getting a lot
stronger yeah he's like actually
yeah that's my new goal I got a [__]
out bench everybody in the building and
I'm like at least I'm I'll bench all you
once while you're swatting me I don't
know I gotta do something dude I gotta
be able to do a backflip I got to learn
oh Tony Hawk I was like What if I kick
flip like [__] [__] he's on the
other side of the wall what if I learned
Jujitsu oh [__] what if I like started
bot
let's just ended up
[__]
[__] all right never mind acting oh [__]
they've been in movies
like what if I could shoot good [__]
baseball
are you good at baseball [__] not hey I
might be able to win at baseball there
we go maybe wrestling
there you go good options maybe
wrestling yeah wrestle Matt Barnes was
grabbing from the knee down the whole
body is his knee down and all this tall
dudes don't wrestle take them down
eventually or he'll just stomp on me
I'm not saying I'm gonna fight our
co-workers guys I'm just saying
physically I'm like what can I do here
man
go out roll all ya
there you go
one hit a bong as tall as you no you
can't I can
I'm gonna go home Happy damn oh yeah
they could just hit the six footer just
looking down that's crazy standing
straight up we don't gotta talk about
nothing
six seven six eight easily
it's crazy it's just a regular bong how
crazy is it thank you guys for making
this possible when we started this
podcast we
we said dude you know he's gonna be sick
if we you know get these people while
I'm doing this our new co-workers are
NBA legends the best boxer of all time
the greatest skater of all time Jason
Ellis's wild ass Kevin Garner Kevin
Garnett's in there too oh my God
the West Coast office
I forgot Kevin Garnett just signed yeah
and you know who his first guest was
right
I think I didn't watch it you know I
watched it
second it came out I went home like
single tier of happiness I had him
started an interview a full interview
okay at our studio basically
oh my god let's go one day I'm gonna
walk in and see that film just I'm gonna
just Wayne's World in my head I'm not
gonna do that [__] in person but in my
head like oh my God
thank you
John Travolta moment yes definitely my
judge volts a moment and I know that
fool gets high
I didn't not realize how much I love
that fool judge holds the man bro yeah
these [__] cool [__] interesting life
too I I looked I realized I only really
knew him as Vincent Vega I didn't really
know a lot oh yeah so I kind of
researched him
very very interesting life he's been
there a lot and he's a he's an
interesting dude he could fly yeah I
can't
that's about it he owns like he owns
planes like the government owns like
yeah he's a pilot he he'd be doing wild
[__] all right now he looks like Rogan
he does beard
bald head
big same bulb yeah just a little bit
taller actually he's pretty [__] tall
he's probably six foot
nice [__] guy though damn dude his
Vibe his whole energy he didn't have any
sort of like weird energy that I could I
sat there and was just watching him for
[__] two days straight literally
he's epic really nice guy I felt really
good about it
that's how I feel about every literary
you know how crazy is I'll wrap it up
but we did a meet and greet with like
thousands of people and not one person
was whack
physics and averages and [__] one time I
won't say where but one time there was
one dude I was like yo get the [__] away
from me like yo don't get stop talking I
wanted him to leave me the [__] alone
but he wasn't speaking
he didn't want to come it was one of his
friends he's like oh the first thing he
said I don't want you bro I was like
okay it's all good hey what's up man I
was talking to his friend I was like the
way he was looking like laughing at [__]
like bro your Vibe is so bad can you
wait in the car please just get away
from me I'll hit you with the face
that's so nice dude but like I'll choke
you to death not for real
you know what I mean with those
unprovoked moments come and you're like
oh I'm gonna take I'm gonna I'm Gonna
Knock You the [__] out I don't want to
ever do that but you know those feelings
just feel that little ways okay
that's why I appreciate Rosie not
telling me anything until the end she
knows what she's doing she knows what
she's doing she knows how I am yeah
the event was a success yes because of
it could you imagine
some guy smiling at you and just
smacking the [__] out of you
[Laughter]
oh we'll wrap it up I'm not gonna be
violent toward people that's not what
I'm saying I'm just saying everybody was
so [__] nice
[__] still went down also come on go
there's crime in Houston lots of people
with guns and [__] there's cold dude I
said I tell you one other thing
I don't like guns don't like them
I don't even own our gun to have a gun
rack all right Willow Wayne's World for
you right there
I saw all right you're really nice the
guy was super dope but I'm walking
through the line I forgot to tell you I
was given I was doing the giveaway and
like
I try not to like go and as I'm walking
back I try not to like hey what's up to
everybody because then everybody just
bam circles me I'm like oh [__] I gotta
get back so that happened because I
stopped to sign one thing real quick I
was like oh oh [__] and then I it's not
like I'm doing a fist bumping like this
like E Honda and [__] I felt weird like
I don't want to leave anybody out yeah
yeah
but also like yo I'm trying to get into
the front yeah yeah I need to start back
on my [__] but this was I'll sign this
real quick I'm like oh hell yeah that's
what I'm like
this is Glock it's a gun case I thought
it was a Pelican case at first like for
a rig and I'm starting to like this is a
gun case
and then I look over and he's like can
you sign this he pulls out his [__]
gun I'm like uh yeah can you hold it
though I don't want to touch it
and I'm signing it like this I'm like I
don't even want my fingerprints on your
gun bro
no it's Texas everybody has yeah there
was girls with pistols right here I
wasn't worried I was just like
he's hiding a firearm okay starting a
firearm this goes against everything I
have and I'm not saying if you run in my
house you won't get shot through the
chest because you [__] will I just
don't like having them but I have
presented to you in line yeah I don't
want to say that right now because
you'll get chopped in half but I'm
saying
not running in my house it's different
it's like ah I don't like them I don't
only time I want to touch when I'm like
this
I feel so bad anyway
and then he goes can you stop my
extended and he pulled out a clip Jesus
and I'm like those are full of bull oh
God and I went I don't want my
fingerprints on this bro can you just
because I'm signing it and it says Yola
with a smiley face a joint it's the last
thing a Fool's gonna see each other I
know
smiley face
oh hell no you had the gun click in
there you had it loaded
oh [__] I didn't even hit that one
yo that did that by itself
that's the Jason Ella's evil laugh that
was scary God damn that was [__]
scary what voice was that Daniel Day
Lewis laughing that's the Texas police
okay
I [__] hate you
you guys didn't hear them
that was a straight I took all the
children to a cave laugh and a villain
can we before we leave season two these
are gone can we do it what tell me what
what are every buttons oh man we got a
couple here guys we go let's do it yeah
I mean we got the you know we got our
our danger alarm
that's scary I don't think I ever hit
anybody with that one we got our little
dad joke
[Laughter]
you got our best friend oh it's only
right
we have all the Crickets over there
all right we got for Josh Wolf
oh in the woods Yuri footsteps walking
behind you
oh we're getting closer if you're
jogging listen to this my bad yeah
these are all stock YouTube sound
effects
all right we got our generics here all
right then we have what
[Music]
we got
Fallen
I brought this one out in the mushroom
trip when you fell from space did you I
was on I was high I don't remember
like that one anticipation
we of course got our
last race done oh they got their own
bank here so we got we got the [__]
thank you I make a whole goddamn mixtape
[Music]
that was such a [__] sloppy mess I
loved that yeah you know so we got a
couple I've gone through [__]
probably 100 of these things we need new
ones now
[Music]
Oh I thought that was like boo I just
put I thought that was like a scare that
was scary no it was a I hate your jokes
boo yeah
I like that one it's like MGMT song
oh yeah that one was queued up I got to
bust them out yeah remember that yeah
all right sorry we got sidetracked but I
had to know what was on there that's
legendary the soundboard the soundboard
we'll see we're gonna see if we can
carry this over but it's gonna be a
little bit more like a talk show I don't
think we're even we might not even be
rocking headphones
we're gonna be doing the live switching
it's gonna look like a show I mean we
can do whatever we want but no more
headphones would be crazy
whole different world like a TV show
hey what's up oh damn that's crazy we'll
see you won't be able to hear your voice
if it's [__] up though but oh we have
a team we have an audience here making
sure it's all set
it's gonna be so much less stressful I
take it back you know every episode I'm
just like I hope the camera's worked I
hope everybody's in focused all 100
episodes Marty I do this too
periodically yeah also look so now
sometimes I'm looking at the camera like
you know just make sure that red light's
on yeah so I try to play into it a
little bit so it doesn't look like we
got indie cameras like
I'm excited these are like damn near
Netflix approved cameras on each angle
season three next week wait for next
week this is season finale but the grand
opening of season three
I'm I'm hyped all right it's gonna be
epic can't say who the first guest is
yet still locking in but I can't even
say the movies is fool's in because
you're gonna know exactly who we're
talking about
can't even do the thing I wanted to do
right now because it could be like hey I
know who that is but you know I'm just
joking the [__] out hey we're
just going to keep it at that guys we're
at an hour 36 how you feeling yeah man
I'm feeling [__] fresh no notes we
just came in here talking let's go we're
a real show all right it feels finally
really doing it yeah it feels and flow
without having to have [__] yeah I love
it
wow Marty it's over big win for the back
end of season two we brought on a lot of
people from the community first
interview YouTube first interviews dip
probably [__] damn you're 10 of them
if you really think about it DJ ghost
fulcrum
young Mike Dollar milk
milk are you gonna be on an interview
before no no five
oh man I know we're forgetting I know
we're forgetting people too color people
though
dude the ddg clip has 120 million views
across across Instagram and Twitter and
YouTube no way to even calculate how
many bro XXL and all that [__] this is a
great season man we had Tony Hawk
Steve-O be real this year
yeah we had some legendary ass fools in
this in this room we had the bad trip
episode we had a good trip yeah I lost
my mind over there for a minute on
mushrooms that was crazy yo it's been
fun do me a favor right now you know
what season two do me a favor
right now in the comments if you're
still here not in the live chat in the
comments go write down your favorite
moment from an episode or your favorite
episode
all right go write it down and then
whoever gets the most likes on that [__]
will send you out of dope dope as usual
box love that you know what I'm saying
not be like oh who's got the coolest
friends to go no I want like yo that was
my favorite moment too you know
whoever's just happens to be like you
know what I saw your comment that was
mine too I already know what mine is
it was when Josh was tripping the [__]
out and I played he touched his ears
yeah instead of rubbing his ears
lose the spot for a second when he
started rubbing his ears he was like a
little kid I kind of felt bad for a
second yeah I know he went back into
like my three brothers and beating the
[__] out of me I was terrorizing him
with this little girl remember yeah the
laughing over your shoulder
mushrooms on this show probably not
gonna
yeah we'll see maybe special occasions
but we're down to back we've been
thinking you know what let's be host we
don't let's be hosts we don't have to
smoke 10 grams in episodes interview
these [__] I want to talk when
you win John Travolta's here one day I'm
gonna go yo Battlefield Earth who who
decided to make that was it you or your
agent but yeah it was my ancient like
all right that was a bad move but it's
okay
you moved on you had Michael Mike was a
great movie and I was just going to that
like look who's talking come on both of
them sick cab driver you're the man
and we'll just keep going from there
that's it not my nice suit
yeah swordfish or what if I just dressed
like him in Saturday Night Fever Ralph
as he got here I would love to get to
the point to where we interview
character interview actors and I dress
exactly like them from there and body
them and see how long it takes them to
go yo are you my guess I am Billy
Madison
that's why I have this tie you know what
I mean oh no you know what you know it's
a sign it's a sign my mic just fell off
it's a sign we're busting [__] out Marty
we're [__] [__] up the mic's on the
Fire
it's okay it's okay I'm gonna hold this
[__] like this and we're ending season
two
look at that remember during the Adam 22
episode my mic exploded when I untwisted
this it all fell apart and the bolts
went everywhere that was sick or during
Rick Ross in season one where I laughed
and I accidentally threw my [__]
headphones off my head that was sick
there's a lot of stuff that's happened
when I stepped on the power cord during
your mom's episode part two oh and we
lost the entire thing that was sick then
I had to snap my finger on The Following
episode
oh when you fake broke your finger yeah
go check that out
yeah Marty stepped on the cord we lost
all audio for the whole three hour
episode that was nuts or when Eric we
lost half the yard half of it and Eric
Khan's dog keto ate my [__] notes yep
literally his dog while we're
interviewing me I looked down and go his
dog ate my whole notes list that I was
interviewing him I was looking down
before we had the TV up and I was like
because I don't like to go so you're
looking at paper plucking at paper
exactly so uh his dog ate my entire we
filmed that right we have it on BTS yeah
see a lot of stuff happened guys this
season's been great all right so let us
know your favorite episode your favorite
moment or your favorite moment from
season two whatever has the most likes
on it we'll I'll hit you up and we'll
send you out a package whatever whatever
has the most likes in two weeks we'll
let it breathe because YouTube comments
take a while yeah it's not like
Instagram you know so that's what I'll
do all right that's it all the way back
to the snack bundles episode you kick it
off God damn legendary all the way
through the new goblins and ogs and just
oh it's crazy
think of the first oh the first episode
we ever did we never released we still
have it in the bank
I wonder one day we'll yeah one day
we'll try I watched it back
one day did we say anything they'll get
us in trouble no I don't think so even
if we did I don't give a [__] yeah you
know that's fine
I mean real trouble not like you know
what you can't cancel somebody don't
give a [__]
trouble to us is YouTube being better
yeah trouble does is like YouTube like
hey
smack you again [__] anyway guys
thank you so much for being here we
appreciate you this is officially the
last episode of season two it's the last
time you're gonna see this room it is
over the new set
I'm not gonna knock this set the new set
looks so much [__] better than the
set it's kind of shocking yeah it's
[__] weird how much better it's the
same artwork
but a different version one small brick
it's all black it's lit the neon pops
more
like it's a real oh my God I can't wait
for you guys to see this [__]
um
anything else you want to say Marty just
thank you guys I'm ready to just
push forward on this [__] spend a lot of
anticipation on talking about it
but thank you for all the support online
and shut man because you see you were
thank you for everybody to subscribed to
my YouTube by the way too no I told
Rosie I I was like four in the morning I
went what did Marty do today because I
clicked your story I saw like 70 and go
what happened and I just kept clicking
it was just people subscribe and go holy
[__] so many people what did Marty do
[__] yeah that's what I think I was like
four in the morning when detection went
oh it's two o'clock I'm not texting this
[__] dude all right let's talk to you
about that yeah I saw that so epic
people shared on their stories so epic
dude and uh
also
shout out to cam brought home the
[__] trip hey let's let's end
the show on a good note cam let's go
Marty explained cam won the championship
the whole league the whole thing through
the playoffs brought it home Sunday when
the bill is lost so it was all good epic
he looks so stoked in this damn picture
yeah the kid in the middle raking that
face is hilarious first thing I noticed
was that kid like damn that that kid's
funny as [__] dude I'm so stoked I
cannot believe they won like that yeah
and they're playing older kids and they
won the whole thing so now next season
they're playing kids like their age now
so we're looking forward to he's got two
weeks off he's right back at it got my
older daughter crushing it in volleyball
all their grades are up so it means when
in fortnite matches all the kids are
athletic yeah crushing
so feeling good feeling good all right
that's a good note to end it on you know
what season three bills Championship
will win the Super Bowl all right all
right first two seasons I might have to
go out on that [__] field
remember let me know first two seasons
they got it they're bringing it home
it's okay you know
time we've only been good for like three
years you know we're working up to it
let's get a Skyrocket and then Josh
Allen sir you will be across sitting
from us yeah scenario's time yeah now he
has time
that was a [__] bird
I know it really didn't mean it to me
but that was brutal now that you don't
have a job for the next couple months
yeah now that you're not keep still
playing in the Super you're most highly
requested [__] interview awaits you
so should we burn him a little and hey
come on the show hey that was a good
that was funny
he's gonna appreciate it was funny that
was funny I got a lot to say about that
authentic mustache it comes with too yo
he looks like he's from Buffalo do you
know Josh Young the uh quarterback for
the bills is from Fireball oh yeah epic
right outside Marseille right in the
valley epic as hell
too cool man that dirty mustache oh yeah
he definitely hangs out the Mexican kids
you better come on here and a wife beat
her and some jeans and chat hell yeah
Cortez
I want to see them cortezes of Black and
Whites all right
We're not gonna do that Josh I'm sorry
all right what if I just dress like a
linebacker what if I just came in pads
I want to start doing these things
Cinema homes Jersey and show it or like
interview Jim Carrey and I'm dressed
just like Stanley IP kisses uh nightgown
and pajamas with a piece missing if you
didn't get I'd be disappointed
so yeah maybe I shouldn't do this
because what if they don't get I'll be
so pissed don't get it I'll take then
they're gonna think I dress like an
[__]
I take it back maybe we'll do this if
we're friends we'll do we'll figure this
out
we did say one day Tony Hawk's gonna
teach me how to kickflip it's true one
day in the office is gonna happen see
episode four I said one day Mike Tyson's
gonna show me how to throw a [__]
hook we said this
we said this
it's on record it's on record and then
now I'm gonna say it I need Matt Barnes
to show me how to do the Kobe thing
where you throw the ball behind you
can't get it my whole life we've been
trying to get it so like mad bar and
Steven Jackson show me something sick
hahaha
new co-workers are pretty cool pretty
[__] cool I'm excited all right guys
this is it season two is over and didn't
think we'd be saying that at the end of
season two which is [__] incredible
feels better I like wrapping it up like
this Christmas your doll episode was
awesome but we needed this though we
need our we needed us me and you the
teacher's not in the room yeah
substitute's gone yes be ourselves guys
thank you so much for being here two
seasons
done epic as [__]
thank you guys wow this is like episode
103.
52 weeks in a year this is almost dead
on two years we started February yeah
that's true yeah might be we started
February 8th and we missed a week that's
exactly a year once we catch up to this
next week yeah it's true damn oh this
drops the 30th our next one will drop
the seventh almost two years to the day
who's gonna land like that wow
we film our new up our first episode of
season three in two days we start up
soon guys so thank you so much for being
here
ah for the last time of this podcast in
this studio thank you so much for
watching this has been the dope usual
podcast this is my co-host Marty O'Neill
I'm dope is Yola have a dope ass day
Fresh Prince
hmm
happy Bittersweet now we leave then I
flipped the [__] table over
oh my God it's over holy [__] when it's
over
[Music]
perfect